this report was hanging otherwise yeah  you only want to take I mean if you can  take it just yeah and obviously this is  not so clear because I can play rookie 8  for instance and if you play if you want  to have Bishop G5 the way the Rooks are  this is not very clear at all okay  so yeah I think I think we should will  go for it  let me just take on this real yeah  she's in trouble against Federal Chuck I  took only two wow okay what are we  missing just rookie four I guess  I guess he just wants to win this  position right because Bishop did yeah  just rookie for it that's what I  expected now  okay but this is brush  that's clear no yeah I wonder uh  did we miss something  it's very possible yeah that position we  were discussing actually even after C5  for graph one it probably wasn't wasn't  as clear as we thought okay yeah  so how winning is this black has to play  one there's really no choice so white  takes twice C7 is hanging